tu aurais été quelqu'un d'autre je
t'aurais balancé la vanne alors il y a
une polémique enfin polémique j'en ai
marre des polémiques moi le mot
polémique c'est insupportable non mais
c'est vrai c'est insupportable il y a un
r c'est que vous aviez vous avez été élu
par le jury parce que vous êtes arrivé
première du jury et combien 3è du public
trè du public est-ce que ça
vous est-ce que ça ça vous dérange ou
pas du tout non justement je suis très
fière d'avoir été élu par un jury de
femme ouais et en plus ça montre la
diversité même au niveau professionnel
de toutes ces femmes qui sont toutes
importantes plus importantes les unes
que les autres et je suis troisème du
publicque c'est quand même pas n'importe
quoi on peut penser que ok je suis pas
top 1 public mais trisème c'est déjà
pour moi très très honorable alors parce
que nous on dit juste nous on dit tout
ici il un petit bémol on trouvait que
que des femmes c'est Géraldine maillet
d'ailleurs qui est là c'est celle qui
est juste entre mundir et
Patrick pasile et donc tu disais quoi
bah dis-leur non parce qu'en fait hier
je disais qu'il y avait donc cette
polémique moi je je vous adore et c'est
pas le sujet mais effectivement il y en
avait qui disaient en gros s'il y avait
eu un le public est mixte et comme le
jury n'est pas mixte du coup ben il y a
une différence alors que si le le jury
avait été mix il y avait des hommes et
des femmes B peut-être que du coup il y
aurait moins eu de polémique sur votre
nomination bon voilà qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez elle t'emmerde non ou non vous
avez raisonin vous avez le droit la
composition du jury que ça soit homme ou
femme n'a rien à voir en fait avec les
polémiques c'est tout simplement que ça
soit qu' eu des hommes ça se trouve il y
aurait eu des hommes le résultat aurait
été tout simplement le même c'est juste
un choix personnel Cho personnel un
choix personnel par même pas de débat
dans les membres du j après de toute
façon la soirée est finie j'ai la
couronne sur la tête j'ai l'écharpe
c'est trop
tard ça vous avez bien
[Applaudissements]
raisono car elle t'a bien
dit sort plus à 21 non mais c'est vrai
mant vous voulez faire quoi après vouz
vraiment Contin continu vos études vouz
parce que maintenant quand on est mais
quand on quand on est Miss France est-ce
qu'on a envie de faire de la télé est-ce
qu'on a envie de faire voilà je sais
pas j'ai envie de finir mes études peu
importe ce qui m'arrive
après il me reste 2 ans enfin oui à peu
près 2 ans plus en fait ça dépend de
combien ça
dépend oui j'aurais aimé faire un master
mais après là je me laisse le temps de
voir les choses venir j'aimerais
peut-être voir toucher au monde de la
mode peut-être la télé peut-être la
radio j'en a une idée je veux dire je
suis pas encore sur le jour de demain
donc je me laisse le temps de voir les
choses et on verra après mais de toute
façon j'ir au bout de mes études peu
importe ce qui arrive vous Z vous Z au
bout de vos études quoi qu'il arrive non
dit si parce que en fait l'avantage de
ma lissance c'est que je peux passer
certains examens en candidat libre donc
même si au lieu de le faire en 3 ans je
le fais en 10 ans ouais elle finira ses
études bien sûr ah ouais d'accord même
dans 15 ans bah elle a pas encore fini
ses études tuis elle est là tu vois elle
est en terminale
tu vois donc je te le dis faut arrêter
euh tu kiffes ou pas en ce moment ah
j'adore est-ce que tu es dans un rêve
oui c'est vrai je vis ma best live ah
ouais vraimentou tu es comme une ouf
comme une ouf quoi c'est ce que tu
rêvais je ça fais pas chier les
interviews tout ça parce que moi ça
m'emmerde en fait le seul truc un peu
chiant c'est qu'on répète tout le temps
la même chose mais sinon en vrai c'est
cool quand même parce que c'est jamais
les mêmes personnes c'est toujours de
nouvelles rencontres puis on se dit que
par les interviews on rencontre du monde
aussi parce que les gens ne regardent
pas tous la même chaîne de la cha chane
télévisuelle n'écoute pas tous la même
radio
donc c'est cool quoi ah oui c'est vrai
c'était c'était quoi la meilleure
émission que tu as fait pour l'instant
le JT c'était bien c'était non mais tout
était très bien il y a pas de truc que
j'ai moins aimé to tu kiffes tout toi tu
es content d'être là ouais c'est vrai il
y a des gens que tu regardais à la télé
que tu disais ouais je vais les voir
tout ça ah en vrai je ne vais pas dire
de bêtises donc je me reprends non en
vrai il y a pas de personnees que
j'avais plus envie de voir plus qu'une
autre ten foutis mais tu regardais la
télé les gens que tu as vu là voilà j'
tu es contente de le voir ou pas du tout
oui je suis contente mais pas de ouf B
si si il est sympa en vrai je suis
contente d'apprendre à connaître
vraiment la personne plutôt que de juste
l'avir à la télé mais est-ce qu'il y a
déjà des gens que tu as vu tu pensais
qu'ils étaient sympa en télé et tu as vu
que c'était des des
chiens je pense que il y a des choses
qu'il faut rester secrèes d'accord mais
ça veut dire qu' en 2 jours déjà elle a
vu des rats je vous le dis c'est sûr
certain je vois dire ai Verdes vous avez
dit que vous étiez une guerrière on a
l'impression que vous voulez vous battre
contre le monde entier que vous vouliez
pulvériser les autres concurrentes c'est
ça qui vous a fait gagner ce côté
guerrière oui peut-être que les Français
et le jury ont vu ma détermination après
j'ai pas envie de les pulvériser he les
pauvres je les aime bien donc j'ai pas
envie de leur faire du mal mais oui
peut-être qu'ils ont vu ma force de
caractère par exemple la manière dont je
suis ce soir peut-être qu'ils ont vu que
j'allais être j'allais être comme ça tu
envie qu'on te fasse chier quoi ouis
c'est toi tuant que tu es B non mais je
pense qu'il faut pas se laisser faire on
est en 2023 on passe bientôt en 2024 se
faire marcher dessus donc ça na aucun
intérêt et donc là pour là tu vas avoir
quelques quelques jours de vacances ou
pas du tout Oui de semaines en famille 2
semaines en donc tu retournes dans ton t
village demain c'est la grande journée
elle retourne dans sa région non c'est
demain ouais avec l'écharpe et tout
ouais ah ouais couronne ah ouais la
totale ah ouais fait ah ouais c'est fou
la couronne elle est pas mal hein elle
est belle hein il la garde après ou pas
oui bien sûr non c'est vrai ah ouais ah
je croyais qu'il a prenit moi non non
non non non elle garde l'écharpe pas une
comme ça pour moi on peut on peut on
peut s'arranger
pour Mo pour conduire j'aime bien j'ai
envie de faire un kiif sans déconner
j'ai envie de faire un kiif mettre une
couronne comme ça avec une petite échar
c'est est-ce que la galette des rois ça
passe bah bien sûr que ça passe
franchement ça passe ça passe vous avez
un talon caché est-ce que vous chantez
est-ce que vous
euh sous la douche quand personne ne
m'entend mais c'est quoi c'est quoi le
chanson ce que vous chantez sous la
douche mais moi je chante de tout ah
mais en plus je suis indcise donc en
général je mets la radio et je passe les
musiques au hasard gen quoi tuimes bien
chanter Sliman
ah c'est pas mon chanteur préféré vas-y
tu chantes quoi vas-y non par exemple
ben l j'aime
bien ça se voit que tu connais pas si
siim bien les
musiattend un autre quoi je connais
hein ch de
je suis pas tes petits copains de Mance
moi
c'est Nouna là oh tu crois que tu t'
arrivrives ici tu crois quoi e oh jeis
il chantait ouais je
sais ta
gueule faire bien sûr j'ai pas le rire
de Mohamed Ali ouis tu connais vas-y
chante là non j'ai dit je chantais que
sous la douche quand personne met une
douche
dou je m'en fous total et tu danses oui
je danse depuis toute petite je même des
cours de danse à incroable j'en danse du
Modern Jazz
j'adore mod jazz comme vous quoi comme
moi faire danser avec les stars
aprèsad vou faire c'est pas a ni de la
mémoire jeémission
d'hier c'estre c'est vra tu VO elle et
Daniel de fon
important essenti de lui rendre hommage
de se réunir on était quasiment plus de
Miss ça nous
ten j'ai plein de questions à te poser
en fait j'ai des questions sur l'ctu
aussi tu vois par sur l' du moment
qu'est-ce que tu as pensé du garçon là
qui été refusé parce qu'il avait les
cheveux roses à l'école pour toi ça dire
c'est quoi ça bah comme pour moi c'est
qu'une coupe de cheveux je vois pas où
il est le problème mais voilà comme ah
oui bah oui g Verdez est d'accord avec
toi non mais c'est vrai est-ce que tu as
peur de cette année 2024 ce que tu dis
ça va être que du kiff ça va être que du
kiff franchement j'ai vu un petit peu
mon emploi du temps ça va être
incroyable déjà j'aurais peut-être le
droit à un son en parachute non ah ouais
voilà quand même ben elle l' fait elle a
perdu son
brushing ça va
ça toi ça va tu as quoi non après
énormément de rencontres de séances de
dédicace mais moi c'est pas sin des
dédicaces qui m'intéressent c'est plus
vraiment aller à la rencontre des gens
parce que comme énormément de monde
m'ont critiqué je me dis que peut-être
en les rencontrant ils vont se dire ok
la fille là finalement pas mal on t'a
critiqué aussi parce qu'on a dit que tu
étais tu étais très mince est-ce que ça
t'a fait ça bah écoutez je choisis pas
mon corps j'ai pas envie d'aller faire
de la chirurgie je mange à ma fin je
mange Mme énormément ah ouais tu m
énormément oui c'est juste que mon
métabolisme comme ça peut-être que si
vous me voyez dans 2 ans je ser serit
plus du tout dans le même corps non
arrête un peu tes
conneries arrête
arrête c'estra ah oui toi tu manges tu
manges grave tu fais beaucoup de sport
ou pas actuellement non parce que tout
s'enchaîne très vite mais de base oui
j'étais quand même très sportif tu
faisais quoi équitation danse athlétisme
tu tu faisais un peu de d'équitation
ouais tu montais
qui non mais c'est êtes vous quoi pas va
me dire un nom genre princesse genreier
je connais nom
n tu
dire
FZ
mon tu vas sur princesse allez tu
arrên
conis il
s'app il y a toujours un aussi je
disz tu vas monter tu l'as déjà monté
fait
gaffe est ner
aujourd'hui tu kiffes soirée Miss France
ouais
ouais j'ai eu la chance quand je faisais
le cabaret de les avoir
toutesant 20 mais elle a un truc en plus
jeune fille elle a un charme
particulierén franchement truc j'étais
ravi qu'elle soit é Luu d'ailleurs mais
je regarde oui oui il la part de rêve
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dis il y
a des critiques toujours
partout même chose' fout ça a raison
quand elle dit je va kiff kiffe
éclate-toi profite
voilà et tu fais rêver des petites
filles ça c'est
ouais même les petits garçons oui même
les femmes mon fils c'est c'est le rêve
en fait d'une femmeout euh non mais
c'est vrai non mais c'est mon fils était
tu pour toi ah ben ça me touche vraiment
beaucoup pu tu t'en fous tu peux le dire
hein non mais chaque personne qui m'ont
soutenu ça me touche tu peux le dire on
s'en fous on tout façon chaque vote
compte parce que des fois ça vois
pas qu même final il rentre dans la
communauté et donc ça ça me fait plaisir
c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut te
souhaiter on peut me souhaiter de
rencontrer le plus de monde possible et
de kiffer mon année comme j'ai envie de
la K c'est ce que tu vas faire hein
ouais vraiment est-ce que tu es en
couple ah ah question ou et comme je
réponds à tout le monde je garde une
part de mystère j'ai le droit à un tout
petit peu de vie privée et donc ça sera
mon petit bout ça veut dire oui ça ouais
ouais ouais dire ça veut dire oui alors
je vais te dire on en a vu des Miss
France qui sont ça veut dire elle fait
ce qu'elle veut elle dit
je te dise l'important dans la vie c'est
de kiffer non ta gueule
particip participer l' dans la vie je te
jure que c'est vrai c'est l'identité
capillaire qu'est-ce qu'il est relou Ji
tu t'es trouvé et ben ne change pas tu
restes comme ça ah ben pourtant je
compte changer non j attend c'est un
scoop tu nous dis ça comme ça les gens
parlent que de ta coiffure tuarres tu tu
veux changer tu veux faire quoi Chau oui
vraiment un jour non mais dans un jour
j'aimerais raser mes ch cheve ressemble
à un petit kiwi laiss regarde il là gr
[Applaudissements]
Kas envie de un petit kiwi non vraiment
ouis mon
du non non ben non je peux pas
actuellementourour guule ta
gueule ça lui ira très bien éoute faire
moi non je vais le faire moimmême non
non je vais le faire non c'est que
j'adore faire raser les cheveux moi mais
moi je veux ZP toute seule
fait zoupe toute
seule Cindy je voulais dire tu as fait
une très belle année ma chérie bravo et
tu es un tu es vraiment tu es un soleil
et je te jure on te kiffe voilà je
voulais te le dire excellente soir et je
te le dis tout le monde tous les gens
qui travaillent avec toi me disent que
tu es un amour merci ben je le fais avec
sincérité honnêé puis la marque est
belle donc Coré é Coré était
super super beau travail très varié
c'est plus en c'est c'est quasiment plus
de 6 mois de travail donc puis après
voilà bien sûr on a nos délégués qui
uvrent pour regarde com trouver des
belles femmes elle me regarde on dir un
ouf ça va qu'est-ce que tu pourrais nous
dire comme mot de la fin et ben bonne
fêteession